alle patientendaten auf dem tablett in
der lukas klinik in nordrhein westfalen
sind die akten digital
die ärzte haben direkt zugriff auf die
ergebnisse aller untersuchungen
ich bekomme die befunde direkt auf das
ipad
so geht das eben viel schneller wenn
alles funktioniert im februar aber drang
ein virus ins computersystem typ tesla
crypt spitzname block i
hier kennt man das problem diese firma
verkauft weltweit virenschutzprogramme
in der forschungsabteilung sieht man
immer öfter das schadprogramm tesla
crypt diese schadsoftware auf den
rechner kommt wird sie sämtliche dateien
auf dem rechner verschlüsseln und dann
wird man mit einer meldung konfrontiert
man soll bitte an bestimmten geldbetrag
zahlen mit mir wieder hand auf die daten
bekommt auch das bayerische städtchen
dettelbach wurde so erpresst
die stadtverwaltung zahlte lösegeld aus
meiner meinung nach sehr bedenklich ist
weil wir eben eigentlich uns nicht
erpressen lassen sollten stellt sich mal
vor wenn das durch geld was da jeder
macht das vergleiche bananen republik
zahlen ist die falsche reaktion klagen
die sonderermittler vom
landeskriminalamt
es animiert zu wiederholungstaten die
triebfeder der geldgier wird da weiter
gestärkt von den erpressern und das
wollen wir unbedingt vermeiden
cyber kriminalität nimmt zu die viren
schützer sehen mehr als 300.000
schadprogramme täglich der digitale
untergrund das ist ein eigener
wirtschaftsbereich das heißt dort gibt
es entsprechend auch services die man in
anspruch nehmen kann
es gibt dort anbieter für software
fertig konfiguriert oder mit einer
aufpreisliste wie dein auto
beispielsweise im lukaskrankenhaus hat
man richtig reagiert nicht gezahlt alle
computer heruntergefahren
die sicherheitskopien aufgespielt nun
sollen die mitarbeiter weitere schulung
bekommen
man kann nur die sicherheit insgesamt
erhöhen
wir sind sicherlich was die auswirkungen
angeht wenn die it nicht mehr
funktioniert sicherlich wesentlich
verwundbarer als früher aber das wird ja
ähnlich sein wenn sie an die nicht durch
menschen gesteuerten auto fahren zum
beispiel denken auch das ist etwas wo
viele hinwollen aber überlegen sie nur
wenn das nicht funktioniert was dann
passieren könnte in der klinik
funktionieren die computer wieder
es sind keine daten verloren gegangen
die ärzte mit den tablets drehen wieder
ihre runden